we want to take an offline first
approach to building web apps where your
app can work offline by default don't be
fooled into thinking offline can be an
afterthought just because we left this
lesson to the end offline support in the
web platform is a very complex topic
which is why we saved it to the last
but first let's define what offline
really means there are a number of
different scenarios that can cause
someone to be offline these typically
boil down to not having a radio or wi-fi
connection but not all of these
scenarios can be detected by making a
connection attempt it's good to keep
this in mind and all the more reason to
build apps that treat the network as an
enhancement